[Music]
sarah is with us in concord new
hampshire hi
sarah how are you hi good how are you
better than i deserve what's up um i
guess so
my husband and i are in baby step six um
and i'm trying to just figure out
establishing some kind of balance moving
forward with
paying off our house we recently
refinanced from a 15 to an eight year
mortgage
um and we um
i'm wondering about though so our
emergency fund is like 25 000
and i think it's probably a little
overkill both of our jobs are super
stable
um and we had somebody suggest to us
pulling out some of that money
to top off a roth ira account and i
think that you're probably gonna say
that's a phone head idea
um but i guess i'm just wondering about
uh about doing that something like that
i mean we're we're
saving four thousand dollars a month
pretty much so
we could probably just cash flow that
for the next what is maybe step
four uh
save for i don't have a memorized door
in front of me uh 15
to retirement we're here we're doing 15
we're doing more than that
okay what stop you're not supposed to be
supposed to be doing 15 and the rest of
it would go
to the mortgage our house yeah
and so if you also say i'm going to
adjust my emergency fund down because i
think it's too
too beefed up then you would just throw
it at
the mortgage okay that makes sense and
you need to make your adjustments on
your retirement accounts down to 15
percent let's get the
mortgage paid off okay sarah what's the
what's the pressure of the roth is that
you feeling that is that a financial
advisor
it's pressuring you advisors yeah
financial advisor
yeah we have like 400 000 in our
retirement
savings right now so i think we're doing
like i'm
31 and he's 35. like i think we're doing
pretty well
yeah um and saving quite a bit
yeah so what's happening sarah i think
is you're getting conflicting advice so
it's confusing to you you're going to a
financial advisor and they're like no
no no matter what you max out the roth
you max out there off well yeah if
that's 15
of your income you do but you only we
just talked about this
uh dave before the show even on
instagram live about
why 15 because the financial advisor is
going to say
you know max out that roth but the
babysitter financial advisors are going
to tell you some of them are going to
never pay off your house
but yeah but all the data all the data
on the millionaires that we studied
which are actual millionaires not at
financial advisors
shows that they the shortest distance
between where you are and becoming a
millionaire meaning building wealth is
to get the house paid off
meanwhile putting some money into the
nest egg so if your 400 doubles every
seven years
okay and we have uh we got
four times or five times it's going to
double
so the first time it if you don't add
anything to it the first time it doubles
as 800
the next time it doubles is 1.6 the next
time it doubles is 3.2
so that tells me you're going to be
worth just on that 400
somewhere at your age somewhere in the
neighborhood of 10 million dollars
well so i don't know why you need to
worry about
maxing out your roth today when the
primary goal should be knocking out the
debt
you may need a new financial advisor
because this financial advisor doesn't
make a commission when you pay off your
mortgage but he makes a commission
when he gets sells you a roth ira
um so and when we refinance our house or
we're in the process of it i guess i
should say
um our credit union is actually doing it
for only 150
bucks uh to refinance from a 15 to an
eight year and
they uh the interest rate is pretty low
it's 2.25
yeah good uh we could that doesn't mean
we want to keep it
right exactly i mean we have a mean dog
but he's small
doesn't mean i want to keep it you know
i mean get rid of it you know
get rid of it as soon as we can yeah
because we could probably pay it off
in much fewer years than six years or
eight years we could do it in four or
five
years if we wanted and then you're done
and then you go and you max out
everything
roth anything you got available to you
because that's baby step seven at that
point
sherry you guys are doing awesome i just
you really are you're killing it and
you're questioning i can hear you
questioning because you're you're
confused and you're like okay i'm
getting this advice
but dave's saying that so it's it is so
just the clear path and that's the why
too hopefully this call
answer that question one more question
just like
at this stage of at this point where
we're kind of
we're paying off our house and we're not
like gazelle intense anymore
in terms of you're not supposed to
you're not supposed to others
right how do we balance having fun
and cash flowing like toys or like trips
or experiences or things that we want to
do
and rewarding ourselves for being
successful to the point that we're at
but also maintain
like moving forward and paying off our
house yeah we go from gazelle
we go from gazelle intensity just to
simple intentionality
and intentionality says after i do my
fifteen percent towards my retirement
no more and after i and then i look and
i say
all right there's only three things i
can do with money at this point
pass that and that's pay off my mortgage
give money away and enjoy money
and all three need to be in your budget
enjoying can be a purchase of a toy
enjoying can be going on a trip
both are enjoying but those are
lifestyle choices
a nicer car is not a necessity it's a
cool thing and you should do it
but it's a toy as you said and so both
of those are just lifestyle and so what
you just do is you look at your budget
and say you know we've got
this number of dollars how many of those
dollars are we going to put to
us i mean others and the house
yeah so sarah yeah so i would say that
you and your husband need to decide okay
our our end goal right the finish line
is paying off that house like that's the
last big thing
how quickly do we want to do it and you
guys need to agree together we want to
we could do this in four if you do the
math yeah we could or we could do it in
five we could do
whatever it is yeah we can do it in five
and go on more trips that's right
back it out and you guys decide and then
whatever money is left that's not going
towards the house is what you guys can
use that percentage of it
to enjoy and to give and then i would
still recommend upping a little bit of
your giving during this process
that was a great call out but having the
end in mind and then backing out because
when it's like
there's that ambiguity of like yeah we
want to pay off our house soon but i
don't know
it feel when it gets in the numbers and
the budget i totally get how it gets
foggy and you're like i don't know if
this is okay or not
well is it okay with your goal like
that's what you guys need that's your
answer yeah i mean
i would not suggest that you have no fun
and no lifestyle increase
and pay off the mortgage in four years i
would rather you pay it off in six years
and have some of each
so that you know if that's the number or
maybe you paid off in three years with
no fun and
four is a little bit of fun and you know
just run some numbers that's right and
you guys decide to actually run some
numbers
okay yes that feels like too much fun
i'd rather
i'd rather do the other one you know
like scott that was on the debt-free
stage paid off his house and i could
just assume
scott's not here on the microphone but i
would think scott's like you know what
i'll sacrifice fun for two years to get
my house paid off you could just tell
that was him right like
and he did it and that's great so it's
your choice but you and your husband's
98 000 in one year
that's right so you and your husband
together need to agree with that goal is
if it's short
lots of sacrifice agree if it's like hey
we're gonna extend another year or two
agree on that but that's the key put
actual numbers to it so it's real simple
take your balance on your mortgage
and divide it by six balance on your
mortgage
divided by five balance on your mortgage
divided by four
those are your numbers and then you say
how much and here's how much i've got to
work with divided by 12 with each tell
us about usually
it's used up i've got this much
disposable income
after my 15 going into retirement no
more you need to back that back down
and you say all right that gives us x
for toys y for toys
z for toys based on the four the five or
the six and then
it'll be right there in front of you and
you'll go that one i feel good about
that one and you'll probably both agree
to it instantly
but you're right the ambiguity where you
don't have if you put
numbers in front of you on it the
numbers will talk to you
and they'll tell you because you are you
know right now you've kind of got well i
don't know about the feeling i just feel
like i should do that
and like it's hard for me to transfer
from gazelle intensity to simple
intentionality
and um i don't you know but you put the
numbers down you go oh well that's the
one that's it
that's the one and you go i can buy a
car i can buy a nice car for that
i can go on a nice trip for that and and
still pay off the house in that number
of years you know and that
so it'll be right there in front of you
and it's not going to end up being
no don't pay the house off early at all
and it's not going to end up being
on the other end where you have no fun
you don't want to do either one of those
and so you i'd rather you get it done to
sound like you got a substantial income
uh rather go and get it done but let's
just lay it out
and when the numbers will say oh that's
the one oh and by the way when you get a
raise all of it goes to the house after
that
because you've already set your
lifestyle budget not upping it with the
yeah that's a good point too with an
income increase exactly